and even bother capturing that pawn
instead he just walks his King over to
the action
that is nice yeah it's unnecessary you
could have just taken that pawn for free
pretty much but he has the idea of maybe
trying to checkmates and in order to
Checkmate remember you can't use a queen
alone you need the support of other
pieces often that's your own King in the
end game so the white king will close
the door it will cover the Escape
squares of the black king and then the
White Queen will try to sneak behind and
deliver Checkmate for example if the
White Queen can somehow get to the h8
square in the corner from behind that
black king is trapped and there we see
the evaluation bar does react this is a
mating net the black king has no
Safe Haven to hide on anymore
and there we go Magnus does finally
admit defeat losing his first game in
the tour finals Magnus Carlsen is now
tied with Liam Leia this is such an
important match and they are now tied
bad game for Magnus Carlson